foreign
[Music]
he lost his parents as a child even
before he was old enough to understand
magic now a debilitating curse threatens
the person who matters most the one
person who was there with him through it
all the one person who could understand
exactly how he felt and exactly what he
had been through
but now no one is there to help the
supposed culprits walk free no one seems
to care about finding them and so it's
left to him and you
this is the tragic tale of Sebastian
sallow
in the original Harry Potter series both
Love and Death are prominent themes both
are also present in Hogwarts Legacy with
each serving as a driving force for one
of the game's most memorable characters
but not in the way you may first think
you see for Sebastian it isn't death for
himself that he fears this of course
serves as a stark contrast with Lord
Voldemort the primary antagonist from
the original series Tom Riddle's entire
motivation and pursuit of power were
driven by his desire to avoid death
entirely Voldemort which means flight
from Death sought to achieve immortality
through magical means trying everything
from Unicorn Blood to the Philosopher's
Stone and even horcruxes Sebastian on
the other hand seeks power in an attempt
to cure his twin sister Anne who suffers
from a curse that seems likely to
ultimately claim her life
the persistence we see with Voldemort to
stop at nothing to avoid death is the
very same persistence we see with
Sebastian in searching for a cure
love is an incredibly powerful force but
love can lead to Obsession it can lead
to selfishness and a near total
blindness at how one's actions can
affect those around them even others
they love even those they call friend
in the original series love almost
always manifests itself in positive
forms and results in positive outcomes
after all it is Lily's love for Harry
and her sacrifice that protects him from
Voldemort in the first place it is
Harry's love for his friends and their
love for him that helps them reach their
seemingly insurmountable goal of
eventually defeating Voldemort
and as for the dark lord himself he
reaches a point where he's no longer
capable of love at all
in Hogwarts Legacy this is turned on its
head you see it's Sebastian's love for
his sister a very noble cause on its own
that morphs into a selfish Obsession
leading to a tragic downfall
in Hogwarts Legacy by observing the
relationships of Sebastian his sister
uncle and friends we can see the many
different forms of Love at work
Sebastian and Anne's love for one
another goes far beyond that of normal
siblings twins often develop deep
psychological bonds toward one another
but even more so than that these two had
to endure a single pivotal event
together
an event that defined their childhood Mr
and Mrs Salo were professors
spent nearly every waking moment in the
cellar Library
noses buried in books Alan Sebastian
were upstairs when it happened
they heard a sudden crash and ran
downstairs but it was too late their
parents had crumpled to the floor
a defect with the lamp in the cellar
caused the room to fill with an
undetectable toxin Sebastian and Anne
were helpless they had no magic yet what
a horrible story The sallows both being
professors were optimistic open-minded
and eager for knowledge with their death
Seb and Anne were taken in by their
Uncle Solomon sallow a former auror
Solomon is bitter with a visible
resentment toward his late brother and
was cursed at their home and feldcroft
during a Goblin Raid and being a former
Aura it's likely Solomon blames himself
at least in part for Anne's curse and
where Sebastian will stop at nothing in
search for a cure Solomon has abandoned
all hope he's scathing towards Sebastian
and angrily rebukes him for attempting
to cure Anne with a shrivel fig this
forceful condemnation has an immediate
effect the frustration from both parties
boils over with Seb at a loss for why
Solomon has given up and Solomon
completely out of patience at the
refusal to accept what he sees as
inevitable the argument between the two
sees and caught in the middle recoiling
in pain a pain likely caused by her
curse but certainly not helped by seeing
two loved ones argue vehemently in front
of her it's here in this moment that
Solomon pushes too far blaming Seb for
Anne's breakdown and while we as
observers don't have the knowledge of
all prior disagreements between the two
it's hard to feel anything but
frustration and anger for Solomon at
least in this moment as an adult who's
experienced loss and pain one would hope
to see him do a better job at consoling
his 15 year old nephew especially
knowing how much he's already lost
instead this argument only serves as
fuel to the growing Fire Within
Sebastian Solomon's quick temper flares
again in a conversation outside their
home just moments after the previous
argument he calls his late brother
stubborn apologizes for his nephew's
actions and reiterates his position to
make and comfortable and to stay out of
the way of Rand Rock and his loyalists
he mentions the healers at Saint mungo's
have examined Anne and declared it
impossible to reverse her curse which is
one of the reasons he uses to justify
his position I think it's fair to ask
did Solomon ever truly care for his
brother and his children or was it only
out of a sense of Duty he agreed to take
them in at all because even if one can
understand his reasoning for not
exhausting all possible options for a
cure there's no denying his struggles
and dealing with his own grief have
destroyed whatever relationship he had
previously had with his nephew Anne
believes them both to be sincere in
their desire to help but ultimately she
believes her uncle is right ominous
gaunt a DEC descendant of Salazar
Slytherin and part of the very same
family that would one day give birth to
Tom marvolo Riddle serves as a foil to
Sebastian throughout Hogwarts Legacy he
too suffers from a tragic past his
parents have even went as far as forcing
him into using the cruciatus curse he
found a kindred spirit in his aunt
noctua as she saw to convince the family
there was more to Slytherin than his
obsession with blood status she also
didn't agree with the use of dark magic
and yet she vanished mysteriously in her
search for Slytherin scriptorium and
never returned unlike the rest of his
family ominous wants nothing to do with
dark magic and while he's curious about
noctua's disappearance it mostly serves
as a cautionary tale for him even though
she had good intentions pursuing the
scriptorium ultimately led to her demise
Sebastian on the other hand shares that
same thirst for knowledge as his parents
that drive to do more to never give up
to persist ominous believes that thirst
for not knowledge is what led to their
untimely demise and now he's fearful for
his friend Sebastian fearful that he'll
follow the same path as his parents and
that of his aunt noctua that's why I
can't understand Sebastian's
recklessness I've practically lost Anne
I cannot lose Sebastian too
please avoid anything to do with that
spell book
with his uncle unwilling to even discuss
other options for saving and and
ominous's resistance to anything
involving dark magic Seb turns to us the
player even before our trip to visit and
for the first time the cunning Slytherin
took the fall for us being in the
restricted section of the library but
later we learned this was no pure Act of
altruism from Sebastian rather it was a
strategic move to place Us in his debt
as Sebastian lends a hand in the search
to better understand our connection to
ancient magic we learn of his hatred
toward goblins which is only magnified
by his belief that it was the Goblins
who cursed his sister in the first place
and from the very moment he learns of
our connection to ancient magic he sees
yet another possibility for saving Anne
you're right we saw what she wanted us
to see we saw what she could do what you
can do but I don't know how to do what
is Adora did well then you shall learn
the keepers can teach you
I'm not sure that they would
the keepers believe that removing
someone's ability to feel pain
it's a highly complicated unpredictable
form of magic one that should be wielded
with great care if at all if at all
you've overcome all of their challenges
you've more than proven yourself you can
wield it you have the ability
[Music]
please
talk to the keepers if not for me then
if I am
thank you
but even as Sebastian AIDS us he
continues to pursue his own Avenue for a
cure largely through dark magic when
ominous learns the location of Slytherin
scriptorium we volunteer to talk to him
on Sebastian's behalf we play on
ominous's love and respect for noctua as
well as his desire to know what
ultimately became of her all with the
hopes that he'll reveal the location of
the scriptorium and we can pay back
Sebastian reluctantly ominous agrees and
the trio proceed in search of Salazar
Slytherin scriptorium notes left behind
by noctua reveal a hopeful start to her
Expedition but the final note is only
one of regret
the only way to proceed is the torture
curse crucio but traveling alone noctawa
was doomed even if she had wanted to
cast the spell with our group ominous
refuses to even consider casting the
spell but not Sebastian almost
instantaneously he cast aside the
feelings of his friend despite knowing
firsthand how the curses have haunted
ominous since this childhood he merely
sees the unforgivable curses as a tool a
means to an end in this case the lives
of all three are threatened if they
don't find a way out and yet there's
something haunting about how quickly
Sebastian cast aside the feelings of his
friend I can teach you crucio
or I can cast it on you wait you didn't
say you knew how to cast crucio because
I'm not sure I do ominous knows that yet
he's left us no choice
I don't you answer following not to a
gaunt's footsteps I think I can cast
this if I have to
although ominous may be physically blind
he is already starting to see the
severity of Sebastian's actions and the
very slippery slope upon which he finds
himself
Seb appears to feel some remorse for
ominous's aunt and even agrees to no
longer pursue anything else with dark
magic but that agreement is short-lived
Slytherin Spellbook reveals the location
of a relic he believes can reverse dark
magic curses he even wants to go behind
the back of his oldest friend ominous to
search for it and so we pursue this
mysterious Relic in an old catacomb
behind ominous's back
but ominous already suspicious of
Sebastian confronts his friend before he
can leave with the Relic Sebastian even
dares to threaten violence against his
friend ominous if he won't allow him to
leave with the Relic it's only through
our intervention and yet another promise
a promise that this is finally where it
ends ominous agrees to back down and
then an attack on feldcraft
we arrive to find goblins conducting yet
another raid on the Hamlet chaos ensues
and Anne is in trouble
[Music]
foreign
boy
what have you done any small chance that
remained for the uncle and nephew to
solve their differences amicably now
appears impossible seb's resolve and
determination to use the Relic are
stronger than ever it's clear he'll stop
at nothing and that's exactly what he
does Sebastian returns to the catacomb
despite the words of us ominous his
uncle and even Anne he raises a group of
infuri inside the catacomb with the help
of The Relic and we're forced to fight
our way through them alone to reach him
and when we finally do we're confronted
once again by Solomon
you have the two of you
of you already
[Music]
The Relic
Sebastian snaps no matter the decisions
you've made in the game you'll be forced
to join Seb in his fight against Solomon
the pain sense of loss and frustration
all morph into a blind rage
[Music]
and in the end Sebastian casts the
unforgivable curse the killing curse of
Vada Kedavra on his uncle Solomon she
cannot be healed Sebastian you must stop
ah I won't let her suffer
Ed
[Music]
this video
the water
no
[Music]
you've made your choice
oh and
what have you done
even having just taken the life of his
uncle Sebastian shows little to no
remorse or any understanding of what's
just transpired even after cooling off
and meeting later in the undercroft I
did it for her he says in reference to
Anne it's only after ominous mentions
that Anne is considering to turn him in
that he finally breaks down only then
does he appear to realize how
destructive his actions have been but
after all this time and all the
decisions he's made can you believe him
or is this just another manipulation the
pleas of a desperate young man who's now
lost so much that he'll say or do
anything to try and reclaim what he's
lost did you hear that you saw what
happened I never wanted to hurt my uncle
I know I can't believe he's gone
how did things go so wrong
I didn't mean it
I didn't mean to oh and I was only
trying to help
I can't leave now I don't need to be
more than ever you understand
you can talk to ominous make him
understand he listens to you
I need to be with Anne
I don't know what to do Sebastian you
don't know
you do know Anne has no one
I regret everything I did I know what I
did was wrong I only hope she can
forgive me
that everyone can forgive me
for Sebastian it was never about the
fear of death nor fear of the unknown
but fear of the known you see he
remembers the pain he remembers the
helplessness the sense of loss he felt
when his parents were gone
and was his Rock the one person he could
rely on and now with the thought of
losing her staring him in the face he
can't bear the thought it is what he
knows to be true about death and loss
his love for Anne made him selfish and
blind and regardless of the choice you
make to decide what happens after he
takes the life of his uncle
Sebastian loses the person he loved the
most